hello everyone and welcome what you are
about to watch is an excerpt from a
podcast that i host every single month
with uh crank gameplays or ethan nesta
that is called red lips orange card that
is basically about idiots on the
internet
dating thought this was just a
particularly interesting conversation so
i decided to break this one out and
yeah we're also joined by autumn farrell
enjoy okay so that's my ridiculous silly
story done
the next one is more serious i think
this is like the first actually serious
story i've shared on the show but it is
uh i did tweet this recently so you guys
might have seen it but uh
it was tweeted by reddit ships what the
[ __ ] ethan
i didn't um the title is how can i
22m start dating a twitch streamer that
i really like
i saw this did read this one yes yeah
so it says there's this twitch streamer
that i've started to watch often and
i've grown to like her a bit
this may just sound like me being a
viewer who's just attracted to a hot
twitch streamer
but she lives in my city and i like the
opportunity yes
right actually exactly correct um
but she lives in my city and i like the
opportunity to maybe meet up with her
and ask her out she's really pretty i
like her personality and it's just
really refreshing to see a girl who's
into stuff like gaming star wars and
some
other nerdy things all my previous
really really rare to find
it's extremely rare it's often the
weirdest part about this to me and it's
like
maybe it's just people who live in like
small towns or something but i feel like
[ __ ] everyone plays video games yeah
and like star wars one of the most
popular properties ever
yeah i i feel the same way and a part of
me is like oh maybe it's just because
like i'm
in the industry or something but it's
like i've had friends be
be like oh man like i wish i could i
could find a girl that's into games and
i'm like
what um but he does go in and say all my
previous girlfriends hated stuff like
that and i can't help but gravitate
towards this twitch streamer
because of it uh so generally like this
first paragraph with like one minor
nitpick
is fine like i don't think that there's
an issue with someone liking someone
that they've seen on the internet
obviously you have to check yourself and
recognize that it's a parasocial
relationship it is one-sided
they don't know who you are you only
know who they are
uh people can go over familiarity you
also don't even really know who they are
but
also you're only seeing what they want
you to see
also um and a lot of people on the
internet like even
if you realize it are not like put on
an an act to a certain extent yeah i
mean generally things are edited i guess
twitch streams
aren't but yeah you know that is also
absolutely fair
and it is difficult to get an accurate
read of someone just based on the things
that you see on the internet
for sure that's definitely a thing but
generally
you know i think this is fine the one
nitpick that i have with it is
i've had people forever ask me how do i
find a girl who likes video games
you look for someone whose personality
you like who has personality traits that
you like don't look for someone who just
you can put on this pedestal because of
this one particular thing that they like
you know like i'm not gonna say don't
find people who have common interests
if you like doing crack find someone
else who likes doing crap to reference
previous story
liking video games and one of the most
popular
uh franchises of all time isn't a
personality trait
like i don't doubt these girlfriends
exist who like hate you for playing
games like that's a personality trait
issue
she sucks on the other hand
of this it's totally a valid thing to
like
you should not go after somebody because
like or like
try and seek out like i want to date a
gamer girl
like look for something else but it's
totally valid to be like oh
i am now more attracted to this person
because they have similar interests yeah
like that's totally a valid thing but
don't
just i think looking for common
interests as well again is fine
just don't uh like he doesn't say that
much else about her
um he does say she's really pretty i
like her personality
whatever that means and then the rest of
it is entirely about it being a node so
it's like
you probably should look for more than
that but frankly i i don't think you
should be
looking for someone a streamer from the
top this post gets worse the first
paragraph again
fine with you liking someone on the
internet fine with you seeking your
hobbies out you know as long as you're
cautious about it uh second paragraph
the stream of social media has her doing
pretty basic stuff like going out to eat
and going to the gym
i suppose the simple thing would be to
go to the gym that she goes to but most
people i know only go to the gym to work
out for themselves and don't care to
float and meet potential dates there
true don't hit on people at the gym it
sucks
my plan right now is to yeah i've had uh
people hit on me at the gym before and
i'll be like
like because you're on a machine you
can't leave
and they keep trying and then you put
your headphones in and then they keep
trying
and i'll be like hey i'm just here to
work out and because you're talking
you're like
out of breath and you can't and it's
just not a good place to hit on someone
if they're not open to it immediately
just [ __ ] off honestly yeah
i've never had anybody hit on me at the
gym but like that's not the
place like you're going there
to to work out you probably have
headphones in yeah and you're also like
probably pretty like sweaty and gross
and just like i thought i don't want to
talk to anybody
actually while i'm there quite frequent
i've worked out with like people that
have
dated in the past and i don't even like
talking to them when i'm at the gym
like i go and like i just don't like
talking to everybody
yeah you know that's so true bruce and i
work out and i was just like [ __ ] off
don't talk about no i wanna
i want to look at your sweet biceps but
i do not want you to talk to me
yeah shut your mouth just something
maybe keep moving
toss a wink all right
um okay sorry he continued by saying
yes most people i don't go to the gym to
work out for themselves don't care to
flood me potential dates there so at
least he had that part on point
my plan right now is to apply for jobs
to work
yeah they do you're absolutely right
my plan right now is to apply for jobs
at vitamin and nutrient stores that i
suspect her of going to
these stores being right by the gym she
goes to but there is no guarantee that i
get hired
nor is there a guarantee that she even
goes there i just really want the chance
to be with this girl and i don't know
what to do to meet up with her any
advice
my advice is this is stalking
nobody [ __ ] condoned this and the
reason that i really wanted to like
mention it on this show is like
so many people defended the guy they
were like you gotta try something
there's this so few options these day
you gotta try don't
stalk someone yeah yeah oh
god what do you think this girl's
reaction is going to be
if like she if you do meet her and you
do go on a couple of dates
and then she finds this post true like
what the [ __ ]
like i would be so freaked out i've
i've matched with like this is not even
remotely on the same level
but like i've matched with a few people
on like tinder and stuff that have been
like fans of my videos and as soon as i
find that out
it's weird and i stop talking to them
because
almost every single time uh well i guess
every single time actually because
either people say it right out of the
gate of like
hey i know you and then i don't talk to
them
which is good of them to do at least
yeah no it's
it's great because i've had other people
i've started a conversation with them
and then later they revealed that
they've known who i am the whole time
and then it's like oh i don't want to
talk to you anymore because this is
really weird now and you've lied to me
this entire time oh
that's someone knowing a bunch of [ __ ]
about you that
that no without telling you i think is
so manipulative
yeah uh that must be really complicated
being on dating out of something i feel
like that's not why
padawan never would is like not knowing
if someone knows who you are
and then they could just share the [ __ ]
that you say
dating is a different way of
communicating
like does it not freak you out either uh
yeah it freaks me out a little bit
i mean they all kind of suck anyway like
the dating app i mean
um and so yeah i don't know
uh hot take they kind of suck anyway
yeah they kind of suck anyway
have you ever used a dating app bottom
oh yeah
i uh i was hit the tinders
pretty hard there for a while they do
suck they're terrible
they're absolute garbage
i can't imagine like being like having
to use a dating app
now not that i'm like [ __ ] famous or
anything but you know
having to like talk to someone and then
after talking to them for a little bit
they're like i also
know who you are it's like oh nope no no
no no don't want that don't like that
modifier not only that but also like
when you do get to the certain point of
like oh this person is
chill and like i'm down to like talk to
them more and then like
this sort of sounds pretentious but like
revealing that you're
an internet person feels really weird
because it's like
when you get to the point of like oh i'm
like down to share like my instagram
with you or something
uh i feel like i would hide it which is
like maybe dishonest and response like
you know if i've ever been single and
someone's approached me at a bar or
something
uh i've not told them what i do for a
living yeah because then i feel like the
whole conversation becomes
oh you play video games on the internet
what is that and then it's the whole
thing and then i give the speech that i
give every time i'm ever on a podcast or
whatever you know
like i don't really and then they ask
you how much money you make because for
some reason
in their mind that's an okay question
yeah how much money do you make sir
um yeah so a lot of like
people did point out stuff to this guy
so that there were replies i think the
whole thing's been deleted now
um of of them being like this is [ __ ]
up and stalking and you shouldn't do it
um but he kept being like i don't know
what else i'm supposed to do
uh and then other people were defending
it and my answer was just like just
genuinely for anyone who's ever felt
this and i'm not going to say it doesn't
happen or isn't common like i'm sure
that people
do i mean they definitely do
unintentionally get attached to people
on the internet you just have to
recognize that that relationship isn't
isn't
real it doesn't exist it is only in your
head that person
isn't in theory real if the whole thing
is virtual if you're trying to date a
twitch streamer
there is no caveat my advice is 100
don't the thought is even invasive um
not i'm also not saying that like you
couldn't meet organically and
fall in love with someone who does that
for a living but when you already know
them and have found them through that
medium as a fan
you are crossing a line the minute that
you try particularly hard to do that
especially if it's manipulative like
[ __ ] trying to get a job where she
maybe goes because you checked her
locations
yeah that's really really weird
it's super creepy yeah for sure like if
you wanted to try to do it in any way
like
talk to her through the ways she has
made herself publicly available and if
she's not into it
don't talk to her about that stuff
anymore you know like yeah there you go
because i think that there still is like
kind of a weird
power dynamic there for sure but if you
like started talking in her chat a lot
and then
like i don't know she started like
replying to tweets or whatever and then
you organically started
having actual conversations that's
totally fine there's still
kind of a weird power dynamic in some
kind of way yeah but yeah
like going to this extreme of
trying to intentionally like see her out
in public
and like and also what is this person's
intentions of like if they do see her
out in public are they going to be
honest and be like hey i watch all of
your streams
he says and i quote if i were to meet up
with her i wouldn't even mention being a
fan who watches her streams i would just
pretend to have never seen her before
we'll hopefully psych up a good
conversation and things that i pulled
from that
so manipulative oh my god
yeah it's [ __ ] weird yeah someone
also said why don't you send her a dm on
one of her socials um which i don't
think is a terrible idea
uh and i made a whole video about this
because i thought it would be helpful
it's like
the biggest issue that i think i have
with with the way that people send dms
full disclosure i don't read my dms but
uh the time that i did because i was
trying to give people advice
was full of people just being like hi i
think you're attractive i am interested
in you
i would like to go on date and my thing
is always
okay but why should i be interested in
you
and people just don't think to sell
themselves it's like i i get why
you're into me i'm great you should go
on a date with me because
i'm horny good point
good point i like it
but people don't sell themselves and i
think that's the thing that people
forget is like
are you funny what are you into what's
something that is interesting about you
that makes you different from other
people who can dm because obviously if
you're a twitch streamer as well you're
probably gonna get a lot of people doing
this
uh that's the thing if you really wanna
dm a twitch streaming you like which i
don't think there's anything wrong with
doing that
um as long as you are considering
everything and not planning to
manipulate them and lie to them
because that would be bad yeah um just
you know
sell yourself tell me tell tell them
what is uh interesting about you but he
did say he
was in it for me i mean basically that's
like what dating is now
so you have to what's in it for them who
the [ __ ] are you and are you going to
murder me
yeah why should i be interested in you
yeah um he said the reason that he
doesn't want to dm her
he says this girl is out of my league in
terms of looks if you don't believe in
leagues and stuff like that or if you're
sorry if you do believe in leagues and
stuff like that
and i feel like actually talking and
striking up a conversation in person
would improve my chances instead of
messaging her randomly
as i'm sure has happened before
um so basically he's like i'm not hot
enough
like well that's also an issue yeah
yep yeah i it's so weird like i feel
like he doesn't even need to
dm her like because i'm thinking of
people that i always see
in my comment sections and stuff that
are like really [ __ ] nice and always
just really supportive and like i know
them like i see them in my comment
section i'm like
oh i know that person and like you know
obviously we're
we're still i don't talk to them
regularly we're not friends
but i feel like that's an organic way of
if she is interested in you she will
then be
organically interested in talking to you
and like yeah
that's really the only kosher way to go
about it